[Music]  hey Brad to the bone yeah we ain't  leaving till her Stevens is it possible  to describe infinity yes yes it is it's  one less than the number of ocean  sequels will be making Brad Pitt makes  his first late-night appearance since  his split from Angelina Jolie and it was  hilarious one thing is absolutely true  you're a solid eight Vinny I didn't want  to seem desperate  the 53 year old actor was a guest on  Tuesdays The Late Show with Stephen  Colbert where he cozied up on a blanket  under the night sky with the late-night  host for the show's segment big  questions with even bigger stars hey  Stevie cold easy  yes Brad a mere pittance eeeem din great  spirits while they're promoting his new  Netflix film war machine out next week  no finishing phone call walk away Brad  has been slowly getting back out in the  public eye since he and Jolie called it  quits earlier this year you know we came  out stronger on the other end  [Music]  you